This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
Hello, everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. there is a lot of back and forth about what we should be doing in our 20s. Even more so, I think, what we should be doing with our lives. Should we be pursuing success?
Should we be content and fulfilled with the slow life? What would make us the happiest? What would make us the most fulfilled? Big questions, very big questions. And a lot of us are looking for one particular answer. The thing is, I don't think we ever will have the answer. but we do have the stories of individuals who have taken the most remarkable, unexpected paths through life and can really share their wisdom with us, you know, what they've learnt, what they wish their
younger selves would know, what they have to say about fear and what they have to say about finding purpose, their mistakes. Today I had the privilege of getting to speak to one of these individuals, a poet, a mental health advocate, you've probably seen her on Instagram, a very wise woman, Victoria Hutchins. And every piece of advice she gave today felt so important and so life-changing. Without further ado, welcome to the podcast, Victoria Hutchins. How are you going? Hi, Gemma.
Thank you so much for having me. I'm so happy to be here. I am such a rabid fan of psychology of your 20s. So this is a thrill. I'm delighted. I'm doing great. How are you? You're doing great?
I love hearing that. I'm doing good as well. What a surprise. Look at us both. Doing good. Full moon at the moment. Have you had any creepy things happen? Any weird energy shifts?
Well, today has been a day. So my poetry book, Make Believe, comes out on Tuesday as we record this. So today I went to the independent bookstore in Houston that I'm doing the signed copies with and signed copies. So that was just like I was crying. all day just because it felt so special. I'm sure it had something to do with the full moon too because it's also a total lunar eclipse.
So it was like a super powerful full moon. Not going to lie, that makes a lot of sense. In like the background of my life right now, so many things have just happened. Literally in like the last 24 to 48 hours. Obviously I'm such a scientific person, but I do feel like that sometimes I really notice when there's like shifts in just like our collective energy as humans. And I definitely noticed that today. So I'm glad I'm not the only one.
I definitely also cried today as well. Okay. I shared a few tears. Okay. Maybe at the same time. Yeah, maybe at the same time. Okay. We've kind of jumped right into it, but I do want you to introduce yourself to the listeners
who may not know how powerful and amazing you are. You're so sweet. Hi, listeners. I'm Victoria Hutchins. I am a content creator. I'm a poet. I until recently was a corporate lawyer, so I left my job as an attorney about a year and a half ago to do a bunch of different things on the internet. So it's been a really strange and beautiful past few years. I love to write and talk and think about mental health. I love to write about Nestle. I love to write about Nestle. and childhood body image, thinking about purpose, thinking about mortality. I know that's a little dark, but those are some of the themes in make-believe and things that I like to talk about.
And so it makes sense that I'm an avid listener of psychology of your 20s because I feel like you talk about those things a lot, Gemma. I was literally, I was listening to that being like, oh, tick. Tick. Dating friendship, which you talk about a lot too. Yeah, all the things we grapple with in our 20s. And you know what? All the things we grapple with as humans, but you've had this like really incredible path. And one of the big reasons I wanted to bring you on is obviously to talk about
vulnerability and hope and art and creativity, but also to talk about big life changes and making career shifts and career changes, not even later in life, but at a time when it doesn't feel expected. So one of the big reasons that I wanted you to come on is not just because you are this incredible healer and to talk about creativity and vulnerability, but also to talk about your path from having that corporate career to doing what you do now. One of the big series of questions and like themes of questions that I get so much for people in their 20s is I don't know what I want to do in my life. I don't know how to figure out that path and I feel like I need to decide right now and lock in for this career.
What was your experience perhaps with a similar feeling? So I will say I think it's super normal to feel that way. I definitely felt that way. And if there's one thing that being in my 30s and having a drastic career change at the end of my 30s or at the end of my 20s rather and the start of my 30s has showed me, life is long. You know, we have way more time than we think we do. and it is normal and okay to change your mind. I think that at least in the U.S., the education system implores you to decide what you're going to do
for the rest of your life when you're 18 years old. And that's just not realistic. So for me, I was always someone who loved creativity. As a child, nothing lit me up like acting poetry anything like that i loved however i think there's a time for many of us where we kind of realize those types of hopes aren't practical or we start to think that they are and i definitely experienced that so i specifically remember the moment that i sort of pivoted away from the dream of doing something creative i was a sophomore in high school and i
I went to visit NYU, which is a college in New York City. And I wanted to do something creative at that time. I wanted to be an artist or an actress. And I remember visiting NYU and just feeling so intimidated. Everything about it intimidated me. And I think on that trip, I kind of realized, okay, this isn't practical. Let me just try to be really good at school. And I will just go the passionless route.
I will just have a job that isn't what I'm passionate about. And look, I still believe in that model for a lot of people. Your career doesn't have to be your passion. But for me, I think I always deeply wanted that. And so even though I stayed the course of like going to a super serious school, then law school, then straight to a huge law firm, that feeling never went away. It never went away.
And so I found myself approaching 30 still having that scratching feeling in my brain. And so I think that you do not have to know what you want to do with the rest of your life in your 20s. However, if you have a gut feeling of not this, it's probably not going to go away, you know? And so I think noticing that feeling that you're desiring a change is a really important step that could happen for a lot of people in their 20s. You know, it reminds me of this beautiful saying that if it's your calling, it won't stop calling, which I really, really like it. And I think sometimes people get really stressed because they're like, well, I don't even have one of those yet. I love that you said we have so much more time than we think because it is 100% true. We just don't realize it because we are so engrossed in the moment, which is a good thing at times.
It's good to be present, but we don't reflect on how many changes have already happened in our lives that we've survived and we've been good at and that have been for the best and how many changes are yet to come, right? We just see ourselves in this present moment. And, you know, at 18, I wanted to be a politician. Like, I went to a political science university, and I just did psychology because it was fun. And then I was working as a management consultant, which I love that we both have these very corporate careers where no one really knows what we do on the day to day, but like they know it's, you get paid for it. To now doing the creative thing.
And I think that battle between passion and practicality is a very, very, very. very present one in a lot of our lives for you did you have a turning point where you were like I cannot ignore this calling this voice this creative drive any longer well so I think I had a couple different turning points in my career there was a moment when I was at my law firm where I had a panic attack on a conference call I was working a ton and And it's very hard to explain. It's the only panic attack, at least like that that I've ever had. I couldn't feel my hands.
I couldn't breathe. I thought I was having like a medical incident. I thought I was having a heart attack or something. And I think after that experience, I knew something had to change. However, I didn't leave law at that time. I went on to go in-house. So I went to work for a cybersecurity company, stayed practice. law, but it was under less demanding circumstances. I had more work-life balance. And it's funny because I
thought that that would scratch the edge, right? I thought, okay, now I'll have time to engage with my passions as hobbies. I'll have time to practice yoga. I'll have time to write. And the first thing that happened when I left my law firm is I was so burnt out that every moment that I wasn't working my new job, I was sleeping. I think we forget that, you know, you think you're going to be able to just dive from one end of the spectrum to the other, but often you're deeply burnt out when you leave a job that has been draining for you for a long time. So that was the first phase. I thought I was going to dive into all these hobbies and really I just slept because it was the first time my body felt I think I came out of that fight or flight after a really long time.
Like survival mode almost. Yes. And important to note, like people think that a weekend off gets rid of burnout, recovering from burnout is like a six to 12 month process. It was long. That's so interesting to hear because that was exactly my experience. And then after I started to come out of burnout, I did start to engage with my hobbies. And that felt really good.
but I found that it was just I wanted more more more it wasn't enough for me to engage with my hobbies as hobbies the more I poured into them the more I wanted to do them until I was because I still had a corporate job that was pretty demanding I was still working eight to ten hours a day but I would finish that and then stay up till like three o'clock in the morning writing poems and just be waiting for the moment I could get away to pour into my hobbies and so I found that the moment I came back to my hobbies they started to swallow me whole very fast and so it was sort of just like rolling down a hill versus a turning point from there i love this swallow swallow me whole totally what it feels like was that your experience because i know you worked a corporate job before the podcast what was that like for you i was literally listening to you being like yeah absolutely i i'll tell a little story a little secret here which hopefully no one from my old workplace is listening, although it doesn't really matter at this point,
but I used to do like podcast work on my work computer and pretend that I was working. So I wouldn't be like, you know, I wasn't, like I was busy, but like I wasn't, you know, I was still busy. But if I could like find time, I would literally sit there and I'd have two documents up and one was whatever I was working on and one would be like an episode. And sometimes I would get in the zone.
Like my peak hours for productivity are like 7 to 9 p.m. at night. And I can just get so much done during that period. And obviously I was working a really intensive job. So sometimes I wouldn't finish work until 7 p.m. or later. And so instead of risking that productivity period to go home and get on the train, I would just use my work computer and then email it to myself. and would just sit there and I remember this like really senior like partner like senior director was like wow you're always working so hard like we need to give you a promotion and I was like this
isn't for you guys like I don't give a fuck about this job like I was just like this is for me exactly that makes so much sense to me and I relate so much and it is when you have a passion that's growing nothing can stop you from focusing on it it's like like the best productivity hack ever to just love whatever you're doing. Like hours can pass and you can just be, it can be like no time past. I know that's a very psychologically supported thing too, like flow state. But. Exactly.
Yeah. It's one of the highest forms of consciousness, highest forms of focus, highest forms of attention is when you feel equally challenged and excited by something passionate and driven by it as well. So this is the thing that we can take from this, right? if you are someone who's sitting there being like, wow, that sounds really, really fun that you two are talking about how you found your purpose and your calling. What can I do? Like, how does that help me? You really need to pay attention to the moments where you feel like you are floating in a task or an activity. The moments where you feel the time is just passing you by, where you feel completely
plugged in. That is what you need to pay attention to. That, urge to just do and make or be or talk or whatever it is, whatever skill or physicality or anything, you just feel like you are just drawn to do it. That is your calling. It might not look like a calling because you're like, how do I make a job out of this? But explore it more and you'll definitely, definitely find it. Did you experience any like pushback maybe from your parents when you were like, hey, I'm going to quit being a lawyer, which is a very understandable job. and become a poet and a healer and a yoga teacher or a practiser of yoga. What was the reaction to that?
Yeah, I think, so my parents were initially very skeptical. I remember going home for the Christmas holidays and telling them, trying to explain, because by that point, it was, I was growing and I was trying to explain to them, this is a career, people do this, because at that time, it was sort of the internet. I'm thinking about leaving my job to do the internet. So that's not even something they've really heard of, content creator. That was all new to them. And so I think they were a little skeptical.
My husband was a little skeptical. I'm lucky to have a lot of supportive people in my life who love me a lot. However, I'm a really pro-change person, I would say. I'm not super risk averse. That's not the case for, say, my husband. He's very, like, he's thinking about the risks. He's an attorney as well, but he's more, has the personality type you would think of when you think of an attorney. Like, he's on me about my taxes and the, just all the risks.
You know, that's where his brain goes. And I try to remember with kind of pushback that you get from people when you want to chase a dream, I think it comes from one of two places usually. It's either fear, like these are people who love you, who they're afraid that it's not going to work out and you're going to get hurt and you'll be exposed and you'll crash and burn. And that makes sense that they feel that fear and that's coming from a place of love. And then I think there's another bucket of pushback. And this, I would say no one close to me, fortunately, pushed back on me in this way. But there's people who express criticism because they resent you and because they would love to do something different, but they wouldn't try.
And so when they see someone who is willing to actually jump off the ledge and try, that's very triggering for them, you know, because if you, anything that you don't give yourself permission to do, when you see someone else doing it unapologetically, it's very, very, like triggering and it creates a lot of resentment and so I think that that's helpful for me to remember people are either just kind of validly afraid for you because they love you and they want you to be safe and happy or it really doesn't have much to do with you and it has to do with that person and things they don't allow themselves to do I'm going to pull out another quote another saying that I talk about on the podcast all the time if they can't be where you are, the next best alternative is for them to drag you down to where they are. I love that.
It happens a lot. Normally not with like close family, loved ones, people in the periphery, people who you maybe went to college with, people who are kind of maybe in tandem with you in their careers, people for whom their own fear is their biggest problem. not and you are you are a projection of all their fears realized basically because you're doing it and everything's going well and they have this fear of doing it and it going well or maybe going terribly and so there's a sense in them of like if i was to do this i would fail and here's this person succeeding and that's unfair because their brain has like cooked up this like crazy scenario
that they're not capable um it's a really it's something to really watch chat for, especially in your 20s and sometimes it comes down to jealousy. Yeah, especially among women in your 20s and thinking about creative careers that require trying publicly, you know, things like the internet or that's many things where you kind of have to try publicly first. I think it's so easy to not ever try because you're worried about that type of feedback and judgment happening, even if you don't have access to it. You're worried you're in someone's group chat or whatever. you're worried people are making fun of you behind your back and it's just it's possible that they are honestly however it doesn't have anything to do with you yeah and you got to climb cringe mountain
that's right like cringe mountain once you like cringe mountain is really scary for the first 100 meters and then it's like a walk in the park like you have to get over the parts of you that feel like I'm not good enough for this because someone else has told me and I'm going to believe them and it's this crazy thing I guess what we're really talking about as well as impossible syndrome is it's this crazy thing where we believe others' judgments so quickly but we never really trust our own it's like what is it about us and how we were raised that is so trusting of someone else's instincts about us but not what we know to be true when you start interrogating that a lot of a lot of stuff comes a lot of spiders crawl out of dark places um i do want to talk about
your experience posting about vulnerability online because I absolutely love how realistic you are about optimism and authenticity and also mental health and self-care. Why do you think it is so important to be vulnerable about the times when life isn't good and isn't perfect? Well, I had a really hard time in my 20s. I had a very dark chapter. really rough mental health chapter, just a spiral. And I think for me, when I was navigating that, a lot of the talk around hope, around mental health, around purpose, felt super alienating. The you just need to find your why. You just need to keep hope. Those sort of things when you're really struggling, at least for me, feel impossible. It feels completely impossible. And so I think that the
only thing that made me feel less alone when I was in a really dark place were things that showed that experience in all of its grit, right? And so when I write about struggling with mental health, I try to be honest about the grit and the depths of the darkness, but also show a light that's on the other side. Because I think that it's really impossible to keep hope when you're struggling, right? But you can stay with the idea being that maybe hope exists in the future. And that's sort of the vantage point I always try to write about the topic of big, mental health struggles. I never want people to feel compelled to try to find hope right now, because for me, that was always impossible. But I want people to know that it does exist in the
future, and that's worth, that's worth sticking around for, that's worth going through the motions of self-care that feels ridiculous when you're really struggling, like all of these things that we do that often feel supportive if we're doing well, like the gratitude journals or whatever. Often, when you're really in it, it feels so ridiculous and pointless. However, these things aren't pointless. It's not pointless to go for a walk. It's not pointless. To call your friend.
It's not pointless. To make a plan for next week. It can feel that way. But I think there's so much value in going through the motions. The title of my poetry book, Make Believe, is partially about nostalgia. It's partially a reference to playing make-believe as a child. It's also a reference to the idea that we can make ourselves believe in things
by turning our attention to them. So when it comes to hope, if we want to feel hope, maybe a big part of that is directing our attention towards things that suggest it exists, towards things we love and care about, right? And I think that even if the emotion, even if the hope isn't there in the first instance, the more time we spend looking for it, the more likely it is to appear.
Psychologically, 100% proven as well. Your brain and you have a two-way relationship and what you feed it and what you show it is what you believe. So say for example, you have very limited hope around what is our purpose here on this planet? What happens after we die? Like, what is all this about? You can focus on all the nihilistic existential thoughts that you probably are naturally having as a human who is curious and scared of the unknown. Or you can focus on magic and everything beautiful that happens that there is no explanation for and the joy you feel around others.
same with maybe you're struggling thinking like am I going to find love you can focus on all the other people saying oh my god dating is so horrific dating is so awful this really sucks or you can focus on those really surprising love stories you can focus on the love you feel for almost everything around you and how eventually that's going to have another place eventually that will land in the lap of someone who will reciprocated in the way you want it to. So I 100% agree with this sentiment and think that sometimes when you are in the trenches at work, in a friendship, in a relationship, just in life with your mental health, you just have to go through the motions knowing that sometimes our emotions do occur in cycles. Hope is bound to return. Something you care about
and something worth living is bound to, and something worth living for is bound to come back around. I really like what you say about hope is, is something that sometimes just has like a mind of its own as well. Like, anyone who struggle with their mental health will know, sometimes you have no explanation. I remember last year, like, from the outside, my life looked literally perfect, and it felt perfect.
I had this beautiful partner, I have beautiful friends. I was doing really well financially. I had purpose and my whole life was falling apart and in like a very drastic way. And then suddenly, you know, I've been going through a hard period recently, which I would have every reason to completely fall apart over. And there's just all this hope around me and there's just all this like, it just feels lighter. And I haven't done anything differently that I know of.
It just sometimes comes back around. I was going to say, I completely agree it's interesting. how fickle hope is. There's a line and make-believe that is something like hope is easy to lose and hard to kill. And it is fascinating in a bad way. Fascinating isn't exactly the right word. But how often I think when these moments of everything appears to be going well often, those are the most hopeless times.
I don't know why that is, you know, but these moments where we appear to be on top of the world, so often. You hear I've experienced that myself as well, that those are people's darkest times. Strange. Like, I really relate to that. And I think it's, I also love what you said about belief and this idea that we can control the extent to which we believe in purpose and mystery of the world by, by where we direct our attention.
Because, and I think you've dealt with this as well. I think I remember listening to you talk about this on psychology of your 20s, but I had a big part of my spiral in my 20s was related to kind of spinning out about purpose and divinity and afterlife and death and what happens when we die. And for me, this idea that I'm allowed to choose what I believe has been life changing. I'm allowed to choose to believe we're doing something here, to believe we're in a loving universe, to believe we have a soul to believe there's something after this. I'm allowed to choose to believe in those things and direct my attention towards things that suggest that that's the case or that help me believe that that's the case. And that's not naive.
That's protecting my faith, right? And that's protecting. It's making me live my life in a way that that's more joyful and more loving. And so to me, it doesn't even really matter if it's true. It matters. But even if it's not true, I'm still glad I chose to believe in things. And so that's been, that's kind of the core, the heart of make believe. and yeah you just touched on it really beautifully.
I have a very similar thing, which I know you just mentioned, you know this. And I had a very similar thought process where I was just basically like, how arrogant of me to assume that I know what's going to happen, but how arrogant of me to assume it's the worst case scenario? Like, every single human has thought about this, but I'm the one who got it right. Like I'm the one who was like, it's this terrible, awful thing, that happens after we die and life is suffering and and I know that fact for sure and no one and
like, huh? Like, we forget that. Yeah, we forget that lack of lack of belief or belief in negative things is also a belief. You know what I mean? It's still just like as much of a leap of faith as the choice to believe. 100%. And honestly, I need that tattoo to my body as a reminder because it was this thing I kept getting into where I was like, oh, it's going to be, it's so terrible.
And I was like, wait, but there's all these people who don't think that. And there's this beautiful theory, and I'm not sure where it's come from, but that we get to choose whatever your conception of the afterlife is, is what happens. Like, that's what it's going to be. And so anytime you get so stressed and negative about very existential questions, put all that energy into creating what you think would be the best case scenario and envision what that would feel like. and create a whole universe around it,
然后我想，等等，但有这么多人并不这么想。而且有一个很美的理论，我不知道它从何而来，但大意是：我们能选择死后的世界，你对来世的构想是什么，就会发生什么。就像，事情就会是那样。所以，每当你对这些极具存在主义的问题感到焦虑和消极时，把所有的精力都投入到创造你认为的最佳情况中去，去想象那会是什么感觉，并围绕它创造一整片宇宙，
that's a much better, that's a much better reason and use of your energy. Absolutely. Regardless of whether it's the case after all this, it is because it probably helps you live a more peaceful, joyful, present life in the here and now to not be obsessed over something horrible happening after this. I love how we've just gotten totally off track
那才是更好、更有价值的精力运用方式。绝对是这样。不管最终结果是否真的如此，这样做都大有裨益，因为它很可能能帮你过上一个更加平静、喜悦、活在当下、不再沉溺于身后可能会发生的恐怖之事的安宁生活。我真喜欢我们俩刚刚彻底聊跑题，
and now we're suddenly talking about death. But we are going to take a tiny break. And when we come back, we're going to pivot and talk a little bit more about anxiety and mental health, self-care. And, of course, your new book. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
突然之间就聊到了死亡。不过我们要稍事休息一下。回来之后，我们要转换话题，多聊聊焦虑、心理健康、自我关爱，当然还有你的新书。2%。这是当电梯旁也有自动扶梯时，依然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。
And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练的科学，以及在我们这个奇特的现代世界中建立复原力的法则。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康与健身专家等人对话，带大家看透那些主导了健康产业的、不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾深信植物油具有天然的炎症性。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim?
让自己经受一些苦难，你就会在经历之后变成一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。搜索“TWO%”，即可在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或各大播客平台收听。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack.
好吧，你可以在《Look Back At It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过那段日期的。包括最近一期邀请马克·拉蒙特·希尔来畅聊80年代快克可卡因的节目。坦白说，84年对我很重要，不只是因为快克。
I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.
我随时都可以聊聊快克，不过为了让大家知道我的意思。我的意思是，马克，这已经是我们第二集讨论快克了，所以我开始看出这里面有一条主线了。而且我们现在还把艾滋病也摆上台面了，所以。谢谢你把那句话说完。对。我觉得对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？对。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, We get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough.
在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时当我们执着于追寻某样东西时，我们会深陷于追逐的过程中，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们却还在追逐。而且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在人世间当一个好人很重要。你成为一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种完全不同的动机，兄弟。确实如此。这也是两个不同层级的信任。我希望你能真正地做一个好人。
Join me, Keer Gaines, is we have. have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice, and sell insolence, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
加入我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，由我基尔·盖恩斯带大家进行关于疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。在2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法院听证会揭露了她言词中明显的矛盾之处。这拉开了长达数年的法庭之战的序幕，旨在证明真相。你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试，并向索伦斯隐瞒，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案件。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Grega lesbian, Michael Marangini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped Podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷加·莱斯比安、迈克尔·马拉吉尼。我的天呐。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在Iheart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
Okay, we are back with Victoria Hutchins. We're having a very in-depth, deep conversation if you are just tuning in now. We've talked about hope. We've talked about vulnerability. we've talked about career change. I want to talk about self-care, because I think that the way we think about self-care has become very commercialized, very aligned with money and consuming more. To you, what does that authentic self-care really look like?
好的，我们请回了维多利亚·哈钦斯。如果你现在才开始收听，我们正在进行一场非常深入、深刻的对话。我们聊过了希望。我们聊过了脆弱。我们聊过了职业转型。我想聊聊自我关爱，因为我认为我们看待自我关爱的方式已经变得非常商业化，与金钱和更多的消费紧密相连。对你来说，真正的、地道的自我关爱到底是什么样的？
I think, let me start here with a very practical thing that costs zero dollars, getting off our phones. That's the thing that no one will see. sell you because it's not in its cost money when we get off our phones right that's one of the best ways if we want to take care of ourselves i think being present being in nature taking walks all the stereotypical things but nothing will feel like self-care if you don't do it with a present mindset so if you go out in nature but you're on your phone or you go for a walk but you're on your phone i think how we do all these different things matters as much as whether we do them, right?
我认为，让我从一个成本为零的非常实用的事情开始：远离我们的手机。那是没有人会向你推销的东西，因为当你远离手机时它不花钱，对吧？如果你想照顾好自己，这是最好的方法之一。我认为活在当下、贴近自然、散步，所有这些都是老生常谈，但如果你带着一颗无法专注的心态去做，任何事情都不会让你感到是在自我关爱。所以，如果你走入大自然，但你却在看手机，或者你去散步，但你却一直在看手机，我认为我们如何做所有这些不同的事情，和我们是否去做它们同样重要，对吧？
And there's also your intention in the sense of are we doing a self-care activity with the aim being to change ourselves in some way? Like so much of self-care when it comes to women relates to beauty practices, practices that help us maintain the beauty standard. And so I think that those things can be things that are acts of self-care, exercising, doing your skin care, et cetera. But if we're doing these things like from a place of I hate myself and I'm trying to change myself, I think that that starts to break down how helpful that's going to be for you. I think self-care is a lifelong journey. I struggle with maintaining a self-care routine still.
还有你的意图，也就是说，我们进行自我关爱活动的目的是为了在某种程度上改变自己吗？就像很多关于女性的自我关爱都与美容习惯有关，那些帮助我们维持美容标准的习惯。所以我想这些事情也可以是自我关爱的一种行为，比如锻炼、做皮肤护理等等。但如果我们做这些事情的出发点是“我讨厌自己，我要试图改变自己”，我认为这就会开始削弱这对你到底有多大帮助。我认为自我关爱是一生的旅程。我现在仍然在努力维持自我关爱日常。
I probably always will. I don't know, Gemma, if you've read the book A Perfectionist Guide to Losing Control by Catherine Morgan Shafler. It's a great book. I literally have it in this room somewhere. Really? It's, yeah. Has it got the matches on the front?
我可能永远都会这样。我不知道，杰玛，你有没有读过凯瑟琳·摩根·沙夫勒写的《完美主义者的失控指南》（A Perfectionist Guide to Losing Control）这本书。这是一本好书。我字面意义上就在这个房间里的某个地方放着它。真的吗？是的。封面上有火柴吗？
Is this a book I'm thinking about? I think so. It has pink. On the front, I guess maybe they are matches. Yeah. Yeah. I think I have, I literally have this book somewhere. Okay.
这是我想的那本书吗？我想是的。它是粉红色的。在封面上面，我猜也许那是火柴。对。对。我想我有，我字面意义上就在某个地方放着这本书。好吧。
It's staring at me. It's fantastic. It's looking at me like, you should pick me up sometime. I think you would like it, not to be parisocial, but based on listening to your podcast for years. I think you would like it. But it, I love that book. And I think that it has really helpful, things that were really helpful to me around self-care in the sense of letting go of the idea of, of balance as the pinnacle of self-care.
它正盯着我看。太棒了。它看着我就好像在说：你什么时候应该把我拿起来翻翻。我想你会喜欢的，并不是想套近乎，但基于多年来听你的播客的经验。我想你会喜欢它的。但是它，我很喜欢那本书。而且我认为它确实有一些非常有用的东西，对我关于自我关爱的理解很有帮助，那就是让我们放下把“平衡”作为自我关爱最高峰的想法。
I think that it's pretty inevitable that we're going to be consumed by different things at different stages in our life, whether it's you're in a really busy phase with your job or you're dating someone new. And that's like consuming all your energy and all your time or you're socializing a ton. And I think that sometimes self-care and balance become another yardstick that we use to tell ourselves we aren't measuring up and maybe self-care looks less like trying to live this perfectly balanced life where you're doing your skin care and you're exercising and you're doing your gratitude journal every day and all these different little things fit in every day and more like
我认为，在人生的不同阶段，我们不可避免地会被不同的事情所占据，无论是你正处于工作非常忙碌的阶段，还是你在和某处新对象约会。然后这耗尽了你所有的精力和时间，或者你一直在大量社交。我认为有时候自我关爱和平衡会变成另一把标尺，我们用它来告诉自己我们没有达标，也许自我关爱看起来不那么像试图去过这种完美平衡的生活——你在做皮肤护理、在锻炼、每天写感恩日记，所有这些不同的小事情每天都安排得井井有条，而更像是一种
letting chapters of your life be what they are being less mean to yourself when your life doesn't look how you're shown on the internet that it's supposed to look i get so exhausted by the those TikToks and reels that are like my morning routine and they do like 45 things. It's just impossible. It's impossible. And so I think that could be part of your self-care, but it also could be knowing your life doesn't have to look like that. The easiest kind of self-care is just giving yourself more space to do the things you want
让生活中的每个篇章顺其自然，当你的生活看起来不像网上展示的那样时，对自己少一点刻薄。那些关于“我的早晨例行程序”并且要做45件事的抖音和短视频让我感到精疲力竭。这简直不可能。这根本不可能。所以我认为这可以是你的自我关爱的一部分，但它也可以是明白你的生活不需要长成那样。最简单的自我关爱就是给自己更多空间去做你想做的事情，
to do and giving yourself more time to just go slower. and that's really what changed my perspective on it was that it's not something that is like if someone is trying to sell you something and say this is going to fix you they are selling you a lie a face mask is not going to fix you some you know new crazy diet is not going to rewire your mind most likely a way of thinking isn't going to do that either what truly does change your life is slowing down and being intentional about where things sit in your life. Giving yourself five extra minutes to get to a meeting so you're not stressed. Giving yourself the ability to order takeaway every now and again because it makes your life easier.
给自己更多时间去放慢脚步。这才是真正改变我对它看法的地方：它不是那种如果有人试图向你推销并说“这能拯救你”的东西，他们推销的是一个谎言。一张面膜不能拯救你，你懂的，某个疯狂的新饮食习惯多半也不会重塑你的大脑，某种思维方式同样也做不到这一点。真正能改变你生活的，是放慢脚步，并对事物在你生活中的位置保持专注。多给自己五分钟去开会，这样你就不会感到压力。偶尔允许自己点一份外卖，因为这会让你的生活更轻松。
For me, I think that self-care is about a pursuit of ease and a pursuit of joy. What systems can you put in place so that actually you spend more time present in your life of them worrying about things from the past or things that are going to happen. Like, it's about anchoring you in the present. And you know what? It's taken me a very long time to learn that. Do you have any other tips for people or perhaps even anxiety tips or mental health tips that you think are underrated currently?
对我来说，我认为自我关爱是关于对轻松和喜悦的追求。你可以建立什么样的系统，以便实际上你能把更多时间花在活在当下上，而不是去担心过去的事情或即将发生的事情。就像，它是为了把你锚定在当下。你知道吗？我花了很长时间才学会这一点。你还有什么给人们的其他建议吗？或者也许甚至是关于焦虑或心理健康的建议，你觉得目前被低估了？
Well, I think that we're in an extremely isolated time right now. And it's hard to overstate the importance of other. people in our well-being. And it's easy to forget that in a media landscape that's showing you a picture of self-care or a good life where people are mostly alone. We're just not seeing much. I think community is really, really important and we've kind of lost that. We're at least in the US. We're such an individualistic society. And it's, It's very easy to when you're going through it, when you're really anxious, want to hide from the world until you're doing better.
嗯，我觉得我们现在正处于一个极其孤立的时代。很难过度强调其他人对我们的幸福所具有的重要性。在一个向你展示自我关爱或美好生活画面的媒体环境中，人们大多是孤单的，这很容易让人忘记这一点。我们就是看不到太多这样的内容。我认为社区真的非常非常重要，而我们有点失去了这一点。至少在美国是这样。我们是一个如此个人主义的社会。而且，当你经历困难、当你极度焦虑时，很容易想要躲藏起来，直到你好起来为止。
I feel that urge still and it's so hard to resist. It's the urge to cancel plans because you're feeling anxious, you're feeling upset, you don't want to see people, you're feeling bad about yourself. I think we should all be interrogating that impulse a little bit more and I'm called, I am among the ranks of people who need to do that. But often we isolate ourselves, thinking it will help when really spending time with people that we love would help a lot more. And I think that the more connected we are to each other, also the more we remember that it's okay to need each other. It's okay to need things from each other. It's okay to call someone when you need to talk to them. I think connection
我仍然能感受到那种冲动，而且很难抗拒。那种因为感到焦虑、感到沮丧、不想见人、对自己感觉不好而想要取消计划的冲动。我认为我们都应该更多地审视这种冲动，而我本人也属于需要这样做的人行列。但通常情况下，我们会将自己孤立起来，以为这会有所帮助，但实际上，花时间与我们爱的人在一起会有用得多。而且我认为，我们彼此之间的联系越多，我们也越能记住：我们需要彼此是没问题的。我们需要从彼此身上获得某些东西是没问题的。当你需要找人谈心时给某人打电话是没问题的。我认为社交连接
is a big part of that and it's a hard it's a hard time to be alive right now between just the state of the world and and it's very very easy to isolate in response to it I think it's super important that we don't I 100% agree this is this whole episode is just me being just nodding along in the background being like yes yes tattoo this on my body this is my life philosophy for people who don't have community you know and we're here talking about about connection being like it is it is an antidote it is medicinal community is essential how do you think people can go about building it you know for me when I first moved to Sydney I didn't know anyone and the way I did it was I just went to the same places at the same time until people started
是其中的很大一部分，而且当下是一个很难熬的时代，夹在世界的现状之间，面对它时非常非常容易自我孤立。我认为我们绝不能这样做，这一点超级重要。我100%同意，这一整集其实就是我一直在背景里狂点头，然后心想：对，对，把这个纹在我身上，这就是我的人生哲学。对于那些没有社区的人，你知道的，我们在这里讨论社交连接就像是，它是一种解药，它具有药用价值，社区是至关重要的，你认为人们可以如何着手去建立它？你知道，对我来说，当我刚搬到悉尼时，我谁也不认识，我采用的方法就是：我去同一个地方，在同一时间去，直到人们开始
to be like hey I see you here you know same I went to the same Pilates classes on Tuesday and Thursday same time I went to the same coffee shops I went to the same coffee shops I went to same book clubs and I was consistent with that and that's how community was built around my routine. What would be your kind of like little tips for maybe just even making some new friends? I have so many because I struggled with this a lot. So I moved to Houston for my legal job in 2018 and the first three years when I worked for my law firm, I was too busy to do anything. So when I left the law firm to work for the cybersecurity company, I had zero. friends in Houston, literally not a single friend, and I had lived in Houston for three years.
觉得：嘿，我经常在这里看到你，你知道吗？我也是，我每周二和周四去上同一家普拉提课，时间都一样；我经常去同一家咖啡店；我去同一个读书俱乐部，而且我一直坚持这样做。这就是围绕着我的日常生活建立起社区的方式。你对于可能只是想结交一些新朋友有什么样的小建议呢？我有很多建议，因为我在这方面挣扎了很久。所以我为了法律工作在2018年搬到了休斯顿，在我为律所工作的头三年里，我忙得什么也做不了。所以当我离开律所去一家网络安全公司工作时，我在休斯顿零朋友，字面意义上一个朋友都没有，而我在休斯顿已经住了三年了。
And so I went on this very intentional process of making friends. For me, the things that worked, I think using the internet does help. So if there's someone that say you went to high school with them or your family friends with them and it looks like you might have a lot in common you're connected on the internet, trying to build a banter with someone on the internet is helpful. just like responding to their stories with little enthusiastic things and then throwing in a hey i notice we're both in this town i'd love to hang out like i find when you act familiar with people they start acting familiar with you and that applies in person too so if you say you go to a yoga
于是我经历了一个非常刻意去交朋友的过程。对我的情况来说，行之有效的方法是，利用互联网确实有帮助。所以如果有这样一个人，比如你和她是高中同学，或者你们是世交，而且看起来你们可能有很多共同点，你们在互联网上互有联系，那么在互联网上和某人培养出一种玩笑式的互动是很有帮助的。比如在他们的快拍（Story）下回复一些热情洋溢的小内容，然后顺便发一句“嘿，我注意到我们都在这个小镇，很想一起出去玩”——我发现当你表现得和某人很熟络时，他们也会开始对你表现得熟络起来，这在现实生活中也同样适用。所以如果你去上一个瑜伽
class sitting you know if you're sitting next to someone asking them have you taken this teacher's class before or just small little questions and then all offering up a little bit about your experience. I haven't taken it. I've heard it's hard or just some little thing you can offer that implies a sense of familiarity. People really open up in response to that. Compliments are a super easy way to talk to people if you're in line at a coffee shop and there's someone that looks like they could be a friend of yours, someone who looks like they're your age, whatever.
班，坐在（你知道的，如果你坐在某人旁边）问他们以前有没有上过这位老师的课，或者只是一些小问题，然后主动分享一点点你自己的经历。“我没上过。我听说挺难的，”或者你可以抛出一些能暗示一种熟悉感的小事情。人们真的会对此敞开心扉作出回应。如果你在咖啡店排队，旁边站着一个看起来可能可以成为你朋友的人，比如年龄跟你差不多的人，无论是谁，赞美是和人们搭话的一种超级简单的方式。
Giving them a compliment about something that they're wearing is a really easy way to start a conversation with someone. And then I think that the process of growing a friendship, we are socialized to think that it should happen naturally. Like thinking about friendship compared to dating. We're very aware that with dating, there's the talking stage, we're going on dates, we're having these intentional moments with connection, there's defining the relationship,
赞美一下他们穿的衣服，是和别人开启对话的一种非常简单的方式。然后我认为发展一段友谊的过程——我们被社会化教育得认为它应该自然而然地发生。比如把友谊和约会做个对比。我们非常清楚，在约会时，会有聊天阶段，我们会去约会，我们在这些刻意的时刻建立连接，会有给关系定性，
there's this very organized process of bonding and connecting. We don't really have that with friendship, but it's still necessary. I think with new friends, new friendships are very vulnerable to fizzling out. So if it's a friendship that seems like it's a great prospect, you're excited about this person, you do have to be pretty intentional about it. I think that hanging out with new friends is stressful and anxiety-inducing, especially if you have social anxiety. but I would urge against canceling too much and that sort of thing like be mindful that if you do that it could fizzle the friendship in the early stage and of course take care of yourself of course do what you need to do but like anything else if you want it you have to prioritize it and I think that friendship is one of those things that we're kind of made to think it just happens but it doesn't.
这有一个非常井然有序的建立羁绊和连接的过程。我们在友谊中其实并没有这个过程，但它仍然是必要的。我认为对于新朋友来说，新的友谊非常容易半途而废。所以如果这是一段看起来前景很好的友谊，你对这个人很感兴趣，你确实需要在这方面相当刻意。我认为和新朋友出去玩是有压力且会引发焦虑的，特别是如果你有社交焦虑的话。但我奉劝大家不要太经常取消计划之类的，你要记住，如果你那样做了，可能会让这段友谊在早期就夭折了。当然，照顾好你自己，去做你需要做的事，但就像其他任何事情一样，如果你想要它，你就必须优先考虑它。而且我认为友谊就是那种被灌输得好像“它自然就会发生”的事情，但其实并不会。
You do have to really be intentional about it. You have to work for it and you have to sometimes feel a little bit embarrassed. That's right. You have to feel a little bit embarrassed about double texting someone, a little bit embarrassed about being like, hey and, you know, instigating. But people love an instigator. Yes, they do. Your easiest way to build community is to be the center of that community by being the one who instigates.
你真的必须对它很刻意。你必须为之努力，而且你有时不得不觉得有点尴尬。没错。你必须为给别人发连续两条信息感到有点尴尬，为表现得像“嘿”然后主动发起互动感到有点尴尬。但人们就是喜欢主动发起互动的人。是的，他们喜欢。建立社区最简单的方法就是成为那个主动发起互动的人，从而成为该社区的中心。
That's right. And be shalant about it. like not nonchal. I would like to be your friend. I, the number of times I've said that. I would like to be your friend. Be clear. Be clear because people don't know and people want to feel affirmed and it's such, it's so much easier to connect when you lay your cards on the table that that's what you're trying to do. My closest friends will tell you one of my longest friends. I saw her last night and we, I see her all the time. We're very, very close. Known me for about eight years. And I remember we, we, we met because she was dating another really good friend of mine, who I'm still great friends with.
没错。而且要表现得举重若轻。不是漫不经心。我想成为你的朋友。我，我说过这话的次数……我想成为你的朋友。要明确。要明确，因为人们不知道，而且人们希望得到肯定，当你把底牌亮出来，表明这就是你想要做的事情时，建立连接要容易得多。我最亲密的朋友会告诉你，我认识时间最久的朋友之一。我昨晚刚见到她，我们，我经常见到她。我们非常非常亲密。认识我大约八年了。我记得我们，我们相识是因为她当时在和我另一个非常好的朋友约会，我和那个朋友至今仍是非常要好的朋友。
And I met her when they were dating and they're no longer dating, but I said to her after the first time we met, we're going to be friends. Like, I just need you to be prepared. Like, we're going to be friends. And I felt like a guy going on a first date with someone and going, I'm going to marry you. Or like, you know what I mean? Yeah. Like, it felt like that just sense of certainty. And I continue to say that to people because I'm like, I'm going to speak this into existence. I'm being the same way that people are like be really clear of your intentions when you're dating be clear with your intentions when you're trying to make friends that's right and as and once they're your friend it continues to be important and it feels weird but we're very these proclamations of love are very
我是在他们约会时认识她的，虽然他们现在不约会了，但在我们第一次见面后我对她说：“我们要成为朋友的。”就像，我只是需要你做好心理准备。就像，我们要成为朋友的。我当时感觉自己就像个去和某人约会却说“我要娶你”的男生。或者像，你懂我的意思吗？对。就像那种带着确信感的感觉。我继续对别人说这样的话，因为我想说：我要用言语把这变成现实。就像人们在约会时会说“要明确表达你的意图”一样，在你试图交朋友时也要明确表达你的意图，这才是对的。而且，一旦他们成为了你的朋友，这种表达继续保持下去依然很重要，虽然感觉有点怪，但在浪漫关系中，
normalized in romantic relationships but it's important to affirm your friends like tell them I'm so grateful to have you in my life you are so important to me I see this value in you I'm grateful for you. Like, all of the ways that we know we have to connect in certain contexts, like dating, are also important in friendship. 100 million percent. I'll also say this final thing about community, because it's my, obviously, you can see how fired up we've both become. I live in this, like, gorgeous little neighborhood in Sydney. And it's like, not a fancy neighborhood.
这种爱的宣言已经被高度规范化了，但向你的朋友表达肯定也很重要——告诉他们：“我很感激你出现在我的生命中，你对我很重要，我在你身上看到了这种价值，我很感激你。”就像我们知道在特定情境（比如约会）中必须建立连接的所有方式一样，在友谊中也同样重要。百分之两亿。关于社区，我还要说最后这一点，因为这是我的，显然，你们能看出我们俩变得多么热情高涨。我住在悉尼一个这样风景如画的小社区里。而且它不是那种高档社区。
It's like not near the beach or anything. And a lot of the people who live around me are older. So they've lived here for a long, long time. Like my neighbor across the road was born in the house that he still lives in and he's now 80. And don't be afraid to be friends with people who don't meet who you think you're going to be friends with. One of my closest friends right now is this woman and she's in her 50s and her name's Emma and we do pottery together. And I see her every single week for three hours, which honestly is probably more than I see a lot of my other friends. we've we've continuously agreed to do these courses together and you know when i announced my book
它不靠近海滩什么的。住在我周围的很多人年纪都比较大。所以他们在这里住了很长很长的时间。比如我街对面的邻居就出生在他现在依然住着的那栋房子里，他现在80岁了。不要害怕和那些不符合你“以为你会和什么样的人交朋友”这一预期的人做朋友。现在我最要好的朋友之一是一位女士，她五十多岁了，名叫埃玛，我们一起上陶艺课。我每周都要雷打不动地见她三个小时，老实说，这见面的频率可能比我见很多其他朋友还要多。我们，我们一直约定一起上这些课程，你知道的，当我宣布出书时，
she came to this like announcement party with all my 20 something friends and she brought like me she brought me a hydrangeer and you know my neighbor across the road his name is frank and like we have drinks like out on the porch so that people will like come and talk to us you have to be available but you also have to again get rid of any preconceived attachment to the kind of the kind of a friend or community that you want people of different ages people of different genders people of different like backgrounds or even like who just never thought you'd be friends with incredible like it's incredible that makes me so happy thinking of you making pottery for three hours a week i i couldn't agree more i have i have friends who are in their late 40s have friends who are in their 70s and those
她来到了这个庆祝派对，周围都是我二十多岁的年轻朋友，她还给我带了，她给我带了一束绣球花。而且，你知道的，我街对面的邻居，他的名字叫弗兰克，我们会在门廊外面喝一杯，这样大家就会走过来和我们聊天。你必须保持随和可亲，但你同样必须再次抛弃对你想要的某种朋友或社区的任何先入为主的执念。不同年龄的人、不同性别的人、不同背景的人，甚至是你从未想过会和他们成为朋友的人，都不可思议。这太不可思议了，一想到你每周花三个小时做陶艺，我就觉得好开心。我完全不能更赞同了。我有四十多岁的朋友，也有七十多岁的朋友，这些
friendships are also so interesting because you get a total different perspective. Not that people in their 20s and 30s are all the same. They're certainly not. But it's so interesting to be friends with people who are really different in age from you because they just grew up in a different time and they have really different stories and they can tell you about how technology used to be. Yeah, I couldn't agree with that more, especially in a time where we're increasingly like categorized into little boxes of people, generationally and aesthetically and just in all the ways like it's so nice to push back on that it's beautiful and like you know the other thing the other really good part about being friends with like older people or
友谊同样非常有趣，因为你能获得一个完全不同的视角。倒不是说二十多岁和三十多岁的人都一样。他们当然不一样。但能和那些与你年龄差异很大的人做朋友是非常有趣的一件事，因为他们成长于不同的时代，有着完全不同的故事，他们能告诉你科技过去是什么样的。是的，我完全赞同这一点，尤其是在这样一个时代——我们越来越被归类到一个个小盒子中，无论是按代际、按审美，还是按各种各样的方式——去打破这种分类真的是太好了，这很美妙。而且，你知道的，另一件关于和年长的人或
different people like specifically older people they're so generous like my partner i don't know if you know this is also an attorney and um which is so funny just another like weird serendipitous connection between us and um my neighbor frank it was like just gave him all these like old designer suits that he had that he didn't need anymore. And I was just like, that's so generous and that's so nice. And I don't know, you just, people just surprise you. And, you know, we're talking about this loving universe, this beautiful universe. Gosh, like, those little moments where someone just sees you and cares about you, even when it doesn't matter, like, you know, it's not necessarily going to help them. It's just like so wonderful.
不同的人（尤其是年长的人）做朋友的真正好处是，他们太慷慨了。我的伴侣——我不知道你知不知道——也是一名律师，这太搞笑了，这就是我们之间又一个奇怪的、机缘巧合的联系。而且，我的邻居弗兰克，就把他所有那些自己不再需要的旧设计师西装都给了他。我当时就觉得：这太慷慨了，太美好了。而且，我不知道，人们总是会给你惊喜。并且，你知道的，我们在谈论这个充满爱的宇宙、这个美好的宇宙。天哪，那些别人仅仅是看到你、关心你的小小瞬间，哪怕这并不重要（你知道的，这不一定能帮到他们什么），也只是让人觉得太美妙了。
I have two final questions for you. The first is I want your best advice that you have for people in their 20s, and it doesn't have to be about what we talked about now. And then I really want you to finish off the episode by reading maybe your favorite poem from the book. How would you feel about that? I would love to read a poem. Let me think on my best advice for a moment here. Yeah, we ask people this at the end of every guest episode.
我有最后两个问题要问你。第一个是，我想听听你给二十多岁的人最好的建议，而且不一定非得和我们刚才聊过的内容有关。然后我真的希望你能通过朗读书中也许你最喜欢的一首诗来为这一集画上句号。你觉得怎么样？我很乐意读一首诗。让我想想我最好的建议。是的，我们在每一期嘉宾访谈的结尾都会问这个问题。
Because, you know, I get to interview so many cool people, and no one's ever given the same advice twice. which is like so wonderful. I have it. This is borrowed advice from my good friend, Shauna Kruger. She's the host of the Leadership and Yoga podcast. She's an amazingly wise human.
因为，你知道的，我能采访到这么多酷炫的人，而且从来没有人给出过两次相同的建议，这真的太棒了。我想到了。这是借自我好朋友肖娜·克鲁格（Shauna Kruger）的建议。她是《瑜伽与领导力》（Leadership and Yoga）播客的主持人。她是一个非常有智慧的人。
She says something a lot. Your dreams are for people like you. I have been thinking about that constantly this week. As someone who was so miserable in my 20s, it's going to make me cry. I felt so detached from my passions. And I felt so sad and I felt like I had boxed myself into a life that I didn't want so early. And it's truly always possible for you to move towards like a more loving, beautiful, true life.
她经常说一句话：你的梦想是为像你这样的人准备的。这周我一直在脑子里想这句话。作为一个在二十多岁时过得非常痛苦的人，这快要让我哭了。我当时觉得和自己的热情严重脱节。我觉得自己那么悲伤，觉得自己很早就把自己框定进了一种不想要的生活里。而一个人朝向更充满爱、更美好、更真实的生活迈进，永远都是可能的。
And so if there is a dream that you have, maybe it's a big dream. Maybe you want to burn your career down and start over. Maybe you just want to find love. Maybe you want community and friendship and people who get you whatever your dream is. You have that dream because on some level it's a fit for you and it's aligned for you and it's coming for you. So I think that would be my best advice. remember that you are a match for what you want. So don't stop hoping.
所以，如果你有一个梦想，也许这是一个宏大的梦想。也许你想毁掉你的职业生涯重新开始。也许你只是想找到爱。也许你想要社区、友谊和能懂你的人——无论你的梦想是什么，你之所以拥有这个梦想，是因为在某种程度上它适合你、它与你同频，而且它正在向你走来。所以我想这就是我最好的建议：记住，你就是你所渴望之物的完美匹配。所以不要停止希望。
Don't think that it's not meant for you. It's meant for someone who's younger or older or has more money or whatever. It's meant for someone like you. And life is long. My editor, Lita, says that. And you have to have time. You have so much time if you're in your 20s, even if you're not, you have so much time. You have time to completely start over.
不要以为它不属于你。它不是为那些更年轻、更年长或更有钱的人准备的，无论那是谁。它是为像你这样的人准备的。而且人生很漫长。我的编辑莉塔（Lita）经常这么说。而且你拥有时间。如果你正处于二十多岁，你拥有大把的时间；哪怕你不在这个年纪，你也拥有大把的时间。你有时间彻底重新开始。
You have time to meet people. If you feel like there's no one in your life who gets you, you just have time for anything that you want. Again, I just absolutely totally agree with that sentiment. It's something I wish I knew at 18 and again at 22 and 25 when I was just thinking that I needed to do everything right now for my life to have purpose, not realizing that you can do it all, you just can't do it all at once. So your favorite poem, because we've never done this on the podcast before, we've never had a poet on.
你有时间去结识新朋友。如果你觉得生命中没有人真正懂你，你只是拥有无限的时间去追求你想要的任何东西。再次重申，我绝对、完全赞同这种观点。这是我希望自己在18岁时就知道的事情，在22岁和25岁时也希望知道，当时的我只是觉得我需要立刻把所有事情都做好，好让我的生活有意义，却没有意识到你可以拥有一切，只是你不能同时拥有一切。那么，请分享你最喜欢的诗吧，因为我们以前在播客里从没这么做过，我们从没请过诗人上节目。
This is a special treat. Choose whichever one you want. Long, short, I want the listeners to really get a sneak peek into this incredible collection. So the poem I think I'll read. I'm not sure if it's my favorite poem in the book. I do really like it, and I feel like it really goes hand in hand with a lot of what we've talked about today, about finding community. So it's called, I have bad news and good news. I have bad news and good news.
这是一次特别的款待。你可以选择任何一首你喜欢的。不论长短，我希望听众们能真正一窥这部不可思议的诗集。所以我想读的这首诗，我不确定它是不是书中我最喜欢的诗。我确实非常喜欢它，而且我觉得它和我们今天聊过的很多关于寻找社区的主题不谋而合。所以这首诗的名字叫：我有坏消息和好消息。我有坏消息和好消息。
If you aren't cool enough for them now, the $800 coat won't help. You can move to a cooler part of town. They still won't want to come over. waiting to reply until tomorrow won't make them text you back sooner. You can learn how to say can and Houston Street and Asai. They will find other reasons to judge you. When you work hard on your makeup for dinner, they'll ask, why are you so dressed up?
如果你现在还不够酷，配不上他们，那件800美元的外套也帮不了你。你可以搬去更时髦的街区，他们依然不会愿意来串门。把回复消息的时间拖到明天也不会让他们更快给你发信息。你可以学会怎么发音Can、Houston Street和Acai。他们还是会找到别的理由来评判你。当你为了晚宴精心化好妆时，他们会问，你为什么打扮得这么隆重？
If you aren't cool enough for them now, you never will be. But there are people who, aren't daunted by the commute to your place, don't care how much your coat costs, won't bump you behind them when the street is too narrow for three, think you're beautiful when you're dressed to the nines, and when you're dressed to the ones, won't be scared away by your dark past or your bad temper, or your worst mistakes, let alone by three messages in a row. you find the right people and you will find them you can have nothing and it will be plenty. Aww, that poem is really, really beautiful. Oh, the dog thought I was talking to her. That poem is like
如果你现在还不够酷，配不上他们，那你永远都不会是。但总会有这样一群人：他们不会被去你家那段路程的远近吓退；不在乎你的外套花了多少钱；当街道太窄容不下三个人走时，不会把你挤到身后；无论你盛装打扮还是衣着随性，都觉得你美极了；不会被你灰暗的过去、暴躁的脾气或犯过的最严重的错误吓跑，更不会被一连三条的未读消息吓退。你会找到对的人，而且你一定会找到他们。哪怕你一无所有，那也已经足够了。啊，那首诗真的、真的很美。哦，狗狗以为我在跟它说话。那首诗就像是
the perfect end to this episode because I think it fully encapsulates everything we talked about, doing things for you knowing that people who love you will find you for what you're giving out that's real and authentic. So thank you so much for sharing. Where can people read more, hear more, absorb more of your work? This was such a delight. It has been so much fun to talk to you. I feel like we could talk forever. You can find me on Instagram and TikTok at The Daily Victorian, make believe, I think should be out by the time this podcast comes out. It is out March. 18th. It's available pretty much anywhere you get books. And you can also find me on my podcast Soulgum. It's new on Spotify and Apple Podcasts. And thank you, Gemma, so much for having me and
这一集完美的收尾，因为我觉得它全面概括了我们谈论的一切：为了你自己去做事，并深知那些爱你的人会因为你所散发出的真实而地道的自我而找到你。所以非常感谢你的分享。人们可以在哪里阅读更多、收听更多、吸收更多你的作品呢？这真的是太令人愉快了。和你聊天太有趣了。我觉得我们可以聊上一整天。你可以在Instagram和TikTok上找到我，搜索“The Daily Victorian”。我的虚构小说作品应该在播客播出时已经上市了。它于3月18日出版。你基本上可以在任何能买到书的地方买到它。你也可以在我的播客《Soulgum》上找到我。它在Spotify和苹果播客上是全新的。非常感谢杰玛邀请我来，
for making psychology of your 20s. I really can't tell you how much it's meant to me over the years. And I know that your listeners are just so grateful for all of the wisdom and vulnerability that you share. love in this episode. Thank you so much again for coming on. And I will leave all of Victoria's links down below. I highly, highly recommend you buy this collection of poetry. If you're trying to get back into reading as well, I always say poetry, great way to do it, specifically this collection. And as always, my lovely listeners, if you have questions, comments, further, I don't know, queries about this episode or anything you heard today, you can always reach out to me on Instagram
并且为制作《心理学与你的二十岁》（Psychology of Your 20s）付出了那么多。我真的无法向你表达这些年来它对我意味着多少。我知道你的听众们也非常感激你在这集里分享的所有智慧与脆弱。再次非常感谢你能来做客。我会把维多利亚的所有链接都放在下方。我强烈、强烈建议大家购买这本诗集。如果你也正试图重新培养阅读习惯，我总是说诗歌是个绝佳的途径，尤其是这本诗集。一如既往地，我可爱的听众们，如果你对本集节目或今天听到的任何内容有疑问、评论或进一步的查询，你随时可以在Instagram上联系我，
at That Psychology Podcast. I would love to hear from you, make sure you leave a five-star review and you're following along for future episodes. We've got some good ones coming out soon. And as always, stay safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. And we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
账号是“That Psychology Podcast”。我很期待听到你们的反馈，记得留个五星好评，并关注以收听未来的节目。我们很快会推出一些非常精彩的内容。一如既往，注意安全，保持善良，对你自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。2%。这是当电梯旁也有自动扶梯时，依然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。
And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves.
在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练的科学，以及在我们这个奇特的现代世界中建立复原力的法则。让自己经受一些苦难，你就会在经历之后变成一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。搜索“TWO%”，即可在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或各大播客平台收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。
We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
我们总是说：相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back At It》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我是个很大的时刻。84年对我很重要。
I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过那段日期的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔畅聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。
It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences,
那真是疯狂的一年。我觉得没有哪个年份比这更对黑人重要了。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。嘿，大家过得怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，
having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen and learn the hard way on the IHard radio app,
进行那些在其他地方绝对不安全、无法进行的诚实对话，但你是和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士在交流。有多少男人带着一身盔甲。它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。而且仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做，在IHard radio应用上收听并学习《Learn the Hard Way》
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在 Apple Podcasts 或您收听播客的其他平台订阅。这是一档 iHeart 播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。